Beto O'Rourke the latest Democrat to
join the presidential race begins day
two of his three-day tour through Iowa
this morning we met the former Texas
congressman and Senate candidate at a
coffee shop as he finished his third
stop in Iowa yesterday he spoke with us
across the street at an art gallery the
name of this senator by the way is the
Art Center of Burlington very very nice
people there this is his first TV
interview since announcing his campaign
we talked about why he decided to run
his plans to tackle healthcare and why
he thinks his limited government
experience will not hurt his chances so
here we are day one 600 days to go till
Election Day we actually counted yuy now
this country has never faced a greater
set of challenges for us to meet these
challenges including the greatest of
them all the existential crisis of
climate change we are all going to have
to pull together we're going to fix this
democracy make it work for and represent
everyone the way in which I have served
you know pass though on the City Council
or in the United States Congress the way
in which I campaigned all across Texas
is all about bringing people together
but as you know the criticism has
already started three term congressman
no real legislation in his own name
lack of experience I think even The
Texas Tribune said you know paper-thin
record
why shouldn't voters be concerned about
voting for you with your lack of
experience well I'm grateful that
ultimately it's up to voters and that
they'll have a chance to meet with me
question me
listen to me I'll have a chance to
listen to them lifelong they'll pass one
with a me raising these three amazing
kids small business owner serving in
local government being in the minority
party for every one of the six years I
was in Congress and yet delivering for
the people I serve delivering for
veterans delivering for our border
community these are all things that we
did by working with and listening to
other people and I'm convinced that it
holds the key to our ability to meet
even greater challenges before us the
only way we do this is by renewing and
fixing our democracy and bringing
everyone in so for many people better
who are really just looking at you for
the first time can I just want to hit
the issues
health care we all agree everybody wants
affordable health care for all Americans
you intend to do that how so the goal
should be universal guaranteed
high-quality health care I think we
complement supplements those who have
private employer insurance with the
ability to be covered under Medicare
that allows us sooner than almost any
other plan to ensure every single
American has the ability to see a doctor
afford their prescriptions or take their
child to a therapist are you from the
Medicare for all
I think Medicare for all is one of the
possible paths
I think the fastest way to get there is
to ensure that people who have insurance
that they like through their employer
able to keep it and that we complement
that with those who can purchase
Medicare be covered by Medicaid taxes
you planning to raise taxes on the
wealthy yes i think i meant i i think
corporations should be asked to pay a
greater share into the success of this
country I think the wealthiest at a time
of historic income inequality should be
asked to pay a greater share I don't
know what the levels should be at but I
know that the tax cuts from nearly two
years ago of two trillion dollars at a
time that we had 21 trillion dollars in
debt at a moment of extraordinary need
across this country was one of those
irresponsible things that the country
has ever done and you said if you are
elected your cabinet will look like
America absolutely
what does that mean and why is that
important to you in a country where the
wealth is disproportionately
concentrated in white families in a
country where the prison population the
largest on the face of the planet is
disproportionately black and brown in a
country that has never never fully
accounted for the cost of slavery of
segregation of suppression of voters of
participation in our economy we have a
lot of work to do and where we can
ensure that those who have the
opportunity to hold positions of power
and public trust look like and reflect
the
three we should make every effort to do
so you had said earlier that you thought
president Trump should be in Page do you
still feel that way it's beyond the
shadow of a doubt to me that if there
was not collusion there was at least the
effort to collude with a foreign power
beyond the shadow of a doubt that if
there was not obstruction of justice
there certainly was the effort to
obstruct justice whether that's firing
James Comey the principal investigator
into what happened in the 2016 election
or in the light of day tweeting to your
Attorney General as president Trump did
to end the Russia investigation because
you know speaker Pelosi has gone on
record she does not think that's the way
to go at this particular time how
Congress chooses to address those sets
of facts and the findings which I
believe we are soon to see from the
Muller report is up to them I think the
American people are going to have a
chance to decide this at the ballot box
in November 2020 and perhaps that's the
best way for us to resolve these
outstanding questions listen he's
candidate number 13 that enters the race
in this case he does not think 13 is an
unlucky number he's the only candidate
who lives in a border city and he said
listen our nation is successful not in
spite of immigrants but because of
immigrants and that's one of the reasons
why he says El Paso was a safe City and
his thoughts on a border wall it went
from no border wall whatsoever to you
know there should be something we have
to figure out exactly what that is but
he's not in favor of a big massive
border wall well one of the criticisms
he's received is that he hasn't been
giving many specifics oh it was
important that you asked him about his
thoughts specifically on health care and
medicare for all he really addressed
that I think in many ways we haven't
heard from him yet no he was very
specific you know listen he was very
popular in Iowa people really wanted to
see him they shouted out questions he
was very specific in all of his answers
I think he had a good day in Iowa
yesterday that will continue for the
next two days he hopes